[Music]
it's that time again Sony have announced
the PlayStation Plus essential offerings
for the month of October 2023 dropping
on October 3rd this will be the first
month since the price hike which
promised high quality games I'll let you
decide if that's true please throw me a
like to support this series thank you
very much let's do this it's soon to be
Halloween season and the horror game is
needed this is the Callisto protocol the
spiritual successor to the Dead Space
series the premise revolves around a
prison moon in which a mysterious virus
has overrun the inmates of course we
play as the only innocent person there
and must get out ASAP and figure out
what happened on the way to the exit the
story is about 8 to 10 hours in length
and extremely linear yet you'll never
feel at ease as jump scares are
everywhere an event could conceal one of
those monsters any Locker could have
this world's version of a headcrab the
feeling of never being safe is something
Callisto protocol does very well the
shooting mechanics are as visceral as
those in the Dead Space games with
telekinesis and other explosive and some
ways to take down the horde something
weird to note about the melee combat
though we must wait to dodge attacks and
then swing back twice as hard and this
is done by swinging your thumb sticks to
evade it's kind of like a boxing game
once mastered it's literally impossible
to get hit at all so that's probably why
the amount of enemies in the late game
ramps up to Blindside you the average
review score is 69 out of 100 with the
major drawback being the repetitive
nature of the game walking down Corridos
waiting for something to jump out the
next game is all about agriculture yet
another Farming Simulator game this time
Farming Simulator 2022 despite being the
most Niche game series imaginable it
can't be denied It's oddly pleasing
plowing a giant field to Perfection with
over 400 engineering Juggernaut
two-wheel and online multiplayer if you
want to plow with a friend or maybe
start a Face-Off to see which is the
toughest tractor in history but
seriously now the management side of
proceedings is Paramount as the weather
and the month of the year continually
change and progress unlike the older
games which made Harvest season all year
round this time your planning really
does matter another introduction is the
production cycle allowing the player to
oversee the complete lifespan of a
product such as harvesting wheat all the
way through to producing the bread
reviews for Farming Simulator 2022 say
this is a 75 out of 100 game and lastly
we have weird West Definitive Edition an
action role-playing game set in an
alternative Western scenario filled with
Supernatural elements featuring five
wildly different stories following
people like a pigman who has a human
brain but their body is stitched
together with pig Parts yeah it's weird
the main draw here is the sandbox world
we live in the stealth and action
options are plentiful and almost all
events in the game are totally
randomized meaning replayability is
assured most reviewers spoke of the
compelling Story the Frantic combat and
player choice being the positives and
the main issue being some technical
problems but that was 18 months ago so
many of those issues should be fixed by
now and as this is the definitive
edition there are many new additions to
like lots of new weapons and
modifications running at around 20 hours
to complete the main campaign weird West
looks like a solid game reviewing at
around seven and a half out of 10 on
average so what do you think of the
month you can be totally honest in the
comments I'll be definitely down there
seeing what people think and also there
are like five free-to-play games
dropping in October so check out this
video if you want to know some more I'm
Adam you're awesome it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
[Applause]
want to get down